ça va déjà mieux dans cette tasse
d'ailleurs charte graphique tedx c'est
peut-être une idée d'ailleurs il y a des
liens pana une infusion bahia pana vous
connaissez peut-être ya pana à la
réunion mais pour ceux qui ne sont pas
de la réunion les ja pana c'est une
plante une panacée qui nous vient du
brésil et qui est introduite en 1800 et
qui est la plante médicinale la plus
consommée à l'île de la réunion pour la
digestion pour le la stimulation pour
les infections pour la grippe
enfin je vais être en forme
rassurez-vous et en même temps à chaque
fois que je prends cette fusion ça me
rappelle ma mère en effet quand nous
étions petit dans la famille elle nous
soigner avec cet ism pana qui reste pour
moi le parfum de mon enfance le parfum
de tout ce que on représente lorsqu'une
famille soigne ses enfants avec des
plantes et si elle a pu nous soigner
avec des plantes c'est parce qu'à
l'époque sa mère et sa grand-mère de
génération en génération
lyon transmis ce savoir quitte à savoir
empirique de bon sens
on dit que ces deux en général une
tisane de bonne femme dans le sens latin
de bonassama ses dires de bonne
conscience et de bonne réputation est en
fait cette tisane
elle va traverser les siècles puisque
aujourd'hui 200 ans après on la consomme
encore à lille la réunion et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement pour que
aujourd'hui ces plantes médicinales elle
soit aussi répandu parmi j'avais dit à
les familles mais aussi peu reconnue au
niveau du du monde scientifique
savez vous que les deux tiers de la
planète celle oms qui a fait ce constat
se soigne aujourd'hui avec des plantes
médicinales et pas des pays moindres
comme la chine l'inde la moitié de
l'afrique la tête presque totalité de
l'amérique du sud
pourquoi aujourd'hui ces plantes
médicinales sont si importantes dans
leur pharmacopée parce que ils n'ont pas
d'autres moyens d'accéder aux soins
lorsque il y a eu le tremblement de
terre d'haïti est qu'haïti était queue
coupée du monde pendant une bonne
dizaine de jours
les haïtiens se sont soignés qu'avec des
plantes médicinales
parce que la plante médicinale elle est
accessible directement elle et pas cher
elle est à portée de main elle est aussi
ancrée dans les traditions les gens
savent les utiliser et ils ont que
savoureux
s'en servir en fait lorsque j'ai perdu
mon père à l'âge de 8 ans eh ben il ya
eu un déclic qui s'est passé il fallait
que je puisse assumer le dernier de nos
blondes famille qui a été extrêmement
solidaire en tout cas ma destinée et je
me suis consacré à l'étude d'abord de la
nature et des plantes
lorsque je suis arrivé à montpellier le
pour les études de pharmacie
j'ai découvert autour de moi des plantes
dans les murs dans les rues qui
ressemblait aux plantes de la réunion
mais qu'ils étaient 20 pour un brin
différent une pariétaire qui étaient ici
très connue parce qu on les consomme
sous forme de braid pariétaire mais avec
des toutes petites feuilles
ici les feuilles de pariétaire cdu 15 20
cm de long du capillaire capillaire
c'est un sirop qui sert à la toux ici on
utilise aussi pour la bronchite etc et
j'avais une espèce d'enseignement décalé
entre ce que je voyais bien sûr j'avais
fait un herbier de plantes médicinales
de la réunion qui a été une grande
curiosité mais déjà à l'époque j'ai
cherché à apprendre à savoir ce qui se
passait lorsque je suis revenu à l'île
de la réunion
j'ai été affecté pour mon service
militaire à l'hôpital de saint-pierre et
on m'a confié une mission un peu
délicate qui essaient de la paillasse on
dit ça en termes de biologie de
toxicologie et là je peux vous assurer
que c'était pas très marrant la
toxicologie c'était la recherche des
toxiques que l'on avait dans les
tentatives de suicide ou les
intoxications et lorsqu'on met le nez
dans un
je vais dire un bocal qui sans leur
hymne depuis quatre ou cinq jours ou un
contenu gastrique
avec tout ce que ça peut comporter de
poison agricoles etc steira ça vous
remet les choses en place et ça vous
remet les idées sur la finalité de ce
que l'on fait on a eu une chance inouïe
c'est que nous avons à la réunion
commencée les premiers dosage de
médicament dans le sens était
extrêmement important parce qu'une
maladie qui s'appelle l'épilepsie qui
nécessite pour ses traitements
un dosage extrêmement pointue dans le
sang est en fait toute cette formation
m'a permis d'acquérir petit à petit la
connaissance et la conscience surtout
qu'il était extrêmement important
d'avoir la connaissance de la plante
la connaissance de la composition de la
plante la finalité
lorsque j'ai pu exercer mon métier de
pharmacien le choc
le blanc aucune plante de l'île de la
réunion n'était disponible dans la
pharmacopée c'est à dire que quand vous
étiez en dehors des pharmacies
il y avait une biodiversité un endémisme
une ombre foisonnant de plantes
utilisées et lorsque vous mettez le pied
dans la pharmacie
c'était impossible de trouver un
traitement qu'ils soient adéquats en
avec la lacc le quotidien des gens alors
on s'est posé des questions et j'ai eu
la chance lorsque j'étais au début de ma
carrière d'aller en métropole assez
fréquemment de par ma fonction de
président de syndicat et de rencontrer
nos amis antillais et là on a mené une
réflexion qui a été comme une cette
réflexion c'est qu'eux on avez été les
oubliés de l'histoire dans les îles
oubliées pourquoi l'en le code noir il
est écrit il était écrit qu'il était
interdit aux esclaves d'utiliser les
plantes médicinales
pour soigner les gens parce qu'ils
avaient peur désintoxication il avait
peur d'être j'allais dire empoisonné ce
n'est qu'à la réunion on a des petits
bijoux de poison qui font que cet arbre
trois feuilles peuvent tuer un boeuf et
c'est très courant on a des d'autres
plantes qui ont pires que ceux là
peuvent tuer lentement par une toxicité
chronique en l'espace de dix à quinze
jours et ces chercheurs qui ont permis
de révéler ces plantes ont montré aussi
qu'avec ces plantes on faisait les plus
grands médicaments
je reviens au code noir et avec nos amis
antilles et on découvre que après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé les
pharmacopées c'est à dire les recueils
des plantes médicinales que l'on pouvait
utiliser à paris et en france ne pouvait
inclure les plantes de la réunion et en
2006 en 2006 un grand combat d'abord
juridique avec les l'assemblée nationale
ensuite scientifique on a pu modifier le
terme de la loi modifiée tout ce qu'ils
comportaient comme exclusion de l'autre
mère parce que il y avait non seulement
cet oubli de l'histoire mais une
méconnaissance en fait de notre richesse
et cette reconnaissance a permis en août
2013 d'inscrire les premières plantes de
l'île de la réunion et des antilles à la
pharmacopée française et aujourd'hui
vous avez la ja pana vous avez le fleur
jaune
vous avez des plantes qui sont
remarquables et qui peuvent être
utilisés en pharmacie pour acquérir
cette connaissance je préside une
association qui s'appelle l'aplamedom
association de promotion des plantes
médicinales des dom et cette association
a repris une idée de notre ami roger
prof de biologie au collège qui faisait
faire à ses élèves un herbier de plantes
médicinales cet herbier était constituée
non seulement d'une recherche d
élève au niveau de leur famille de la
gramoune c'est à dire des personnes
ressources âgés qu'ils connaissent
empiriquement les plantes mais aussi un
petit herbiers avec un questionnaire
simple quelle plante est la plus
utilisée
comment l'utilisent avec quels remèdes
avec quel mélange et cet herbier
constitue une base de données
extraordinaire qui aujourd'hui après
huit ans d'exercice huit ans d'existence
nous avons constitué une base de donnée
à la flamme et d'hommes qui est
remarquable c'est le concours herbages
pays qui veut dire en créole les plantes
médicinales du pays aidant ces plantes
médicinales nous avons bien sûr les
plantes les plus utilisés mais aussi et
c'est là où c'est très intéressant des
plantes endémiques que l'on trouve à la
réunion donc qu'ils peuvent être
étudiées et je remercie tous les
chercheurs chimiste biochimiste tous
ceux qui se sont investis à la réunion
dans la reconnaissance de ces plantes
pour permettre à ces plantes d'être
demain des médicaments à part entière et
ses médicaments aujourd'hui reconnue
peuvent être utilisés dans le monde
médical
parce qu'on peut être en même temps
reconnaissant de la tradition mais aussi
utiliser une phytothérapie c'est la
façon de se soigner par les plantes de
notre époque c'est-à-dire clinique
je vais vous expliquer en fait la
tradition c'est un peu des études
cliniques du pauvre qui permettent de
reconnaître une plante avec des années
des années d'utilisation et l'empirisme
a fait qu'on a écarté des plantes
toxiques on a écarté les gens qui sont
morts en écarter ceux qui ont fait le
mauvais choix et on garde quelque part
le bon choix pour pouvoir se soigner
donc c'est possible de se soigner avec
des plantes médicinales qui aujourd'hui
ont fait la preuve de leur efficacité
mais aujourd'hui principe de précaution
on en demande plus il faut que cette
plante est véritablement non seulement
fait la preuve mais dont on connaisse
les effets secondaires et donc on fait
appel aujourd'hui à des cliniciens à des
chercheurs
qui vont étudier cette plante mais cette
fois ci en étudiant les organes sur
lequel elle agit et en respectant
l'individu et par bonheur dans nos îles
nous avons besoin d'une filière
économique autonome pour pouvoir
exploiter nos richesses pour aux
bienfaits de nos de nos habitants et
cette plante représente aujourd'hui une
amorce de filière économique original
endémique en tout cas porter de pleins
d'espoir il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de la cohésion de tous
ces chercheurs notent is and her qui
nous ont transmis les recettes les des
familles qui permettent cette
transmission orale et aussi ses enfants
qui transcrivent de façon écrite la
tradition avec à la clé les universités
tous les chercheurs les médecins les
pharmaciens tous ceux qui sont là pour
acquérir de la connaissance et enfin le
message que je voudrais faire passer
c'est un message à la jeunesse
un message qui permet à tous ceux qui
vont se soigner de faire un bon choix
aujourd'hui pour des petits mots il
n'est pas nécessaire de prendre une
molécule chimique puissante dont les
effets secondaires sont connus lorsque
l'on utilise cette plante on n'aura pas
ses effets secondaires
donc il est possible de faire des choix
et c'est vous qui avaient ce choix en
prenant des plantes médicinales pour des
petits mots et je vous remercie